we've been missing you on Game of
Thrones since very early on but you
still always come back you've supported
this cast what does it mean for you to
be here tonight on the final season
premiere it's an honor I mean I love
Dave and Dan that's really Dave and Dan
and Amelia get this we won millions to
so it's just yeah it's a beautiful thing
to be a part of the show so what's your
typical game of thrones watch party
night like how do you guys watch it on a
couch like how do you guys prepare for
it together penny well it depends where
we are in the world if we're at a place
that isn't ours maybe a real television
and there's usually like some nice
lighting and oh going on now your former
on-screen wife Amelia just opened up
about some health conditions that she
was battling through around the tending
you guys were starring on the show
together what does it mean for you to
see what she's overcome and and what do
you want to say about her today well
kind of being part of that whole
situation for a very long time so we've
had so many scares and trying to find
the right way to come out and help and I
just think it's beautiful that she's
gonna I mean she's so brave and then
helping the world then trying to raise
awareness in very sad almost lost her
numerous times so
I love her to bits and she's here and
she's going to do great things with it
and teach the world and how are you or
who are you both rooting for to end up
on the Iron Throne at the end
tenaris Khaleesi Khaleesi a little just
rocky I put a little Drogo in there too
those rogue on a little uh
jigeon I'm not the ID on me
[Music]